welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of smiley or at
least 30 people have been killed in a
car bomb attack in the capital Mogadishu
dozens more afeared dead in the blast
near a security checkpoint during rush
hour now local media are reporting that
for Turkish engineers were working
nearby the checkpoint and are amongst
the dead let's get the very latest from
Haruma tosser our correspondent joining
me from Nairobi in neighboring Kenya
she's on the phone
obviously sketchy details at the moment
herro about the numbers of dead and
injured but what are you hearing about
the explosion
well you're right there's not much
information coming out yet in terms of
the digital the official death toll for
now is around 30 but they are fears more
people could have been killed you only
find out in a couple of hours maybe some
of those who've been killed include
Somali police officers and some women
have a very busy checkpoint in Mogadishu
at this time of the day in the morning
people would have been going about their
business driving around going to shops
going to the market so you can
understand it was probably very very
crowded and we told because of all this
chaos a teachers are trying to reach
anyone who'd be able to take them to
hospitals and that's insane time again
because of the chaos that are happening
on the ground in addition the security
situation has always been of concern to
the international community and
certainly those people that live in the
capital one wonders then who will claim
responsibility because at the moment no
one has yes no one has yet claimed
responsibility but in the past the group
al-shabaab Jews we pay responsibility
for these attacks in this part of the
world especially in Mogadishu
they have a number of demands some of
them including the ones the Athenian
soldiers who are based in the country to
meet and in previous years some people
thought it has been ambushed
or attacked sometimes the faces
sometimes on the road and al-shabaab has
claimed responsibility but right now no
one yet is clear is one village to the
priority so officials
anyone who's been injured to give them
to any hospital or clinic section helps
in the danger
well can we'll continue to monitor what
comes out of Mogadishu in the coming
hours and of course we'll join you later
in the program thanks Otis there are
correspondent on the phone from Nairobi
and neighbor in Kenya